you might be familiar with the
conservative blogger and radio host
Erik Erikson he said yesterday that he
knows who leaked the news about Donald
Trump handing over sensitive
intelligence about Isis to foreign
diplomats last week at the White House
we've since learned that the Intel
allegedly came from Israel not a
surprising thing when the original
report was a Middle Eastern Ally had
given us the information Ericsson is
saying that the information is number
one totally reliable but he also says
that most of the reports of the incident
are not emphasizing enough how damaging
spreading divulging leaking this type of
information to Russia could be in terms
of our relationships with other
countries Ericsson said in a blog post
yesterday quote this is a real problem
and I treat this story very seriously
because I know just how credible
competent and serious as well as
seriously pro-trump at least one of the
sources is Ericsson is a conservative
sort of an extremist conservative at
that anti-trump conservative and despite
that fact like many conservatives he is
very concerned about the carelessness
that Donald Trump is displaying when he
chooses to give this information to
Russia and apparently the person who
leaked the information about Trump's
spilling the beans to Russia according
to Ericsson is also a conservative and
pro Trump that's what I think is
starting to change the tenor of what
we're seeing pat which is that the
people who are leaking some of these
bombshells from within the
administration they are not random
moderate or liberal ideologues that have
somehow slipped in and just want to hurt
Trump these are conservatives who seem
genuinely concerned about what Donald
Trump is doing and that's who we're
getting this information from and so the
notion that these are left-wing bomb
throwers in there is absolutely false
Erick Erickson also said and we'll put
the second quote up on the screen for
you you can call these sources disloyal
traitors or whatever you want but please
ask yourself a question if the president
through inexperience and ignorance is
jeopardizing our national security and
will not take advice or corrective
action what other means are available to
the president - listen at record
recognize the error of his ways that is
spot-on Erickson said in the blog post
that he knows people who are close to
the president who say that trumps
insecurity and egotism are making him
unable to take any criticism whatsoever
that it's all any criticism of Trump at
all is considered a personal attack this
is completely believable this is the
Trump we've known for a long time
there's no lack of consistency here
lastly from Erik Erikson's blog post
quote I am told that what the president
did is actually far worse than what is
being reported the president does not
seem to realize or appreciate that is
bragging can undermine relationships
with our allies and with human
intelligence sources he also does not
seem to appreciate that his loose lips
can get valuable assets in the field
killed Israel which by all indications
is our source of this Intel is obviously
one of our most important allies in the
Middle East whatever you think about
Benjamin Netanyahu I'm significantly
against Benjamin Netanyahu whatever you
think about Israel
there's no denying the value of the
Alliance with regard to intelligence if
you want to be fighting Isis you have to
recognize the importance of Israel being
able to trust us with information and
like Erick Erickson said it can
compromise the original source of the
information you want to talk about
unmasking and putting CIA people at risk
these types of loose lips Pat can
actually put in human human intelligence
assets people at risk in the Middle East
yeah it is interesting that this is
coming from Erick Erickson who is of
course a right winger but it's also
important to point out that he was
really never in support of Trump he was
kind of like a glint back in that he's
been a never Trump er yeah dunno about
it and a lot of people are saying he's
just a bomb thrower because of that and
there really wasn't a place for him it
seemed after Trump won the election and
then got inaugurated but now that
there's talks about a revolt against
Trump about possible impeachment idea
he's becoming more relevant and this is
the angle that he's trying to push there
and and you know what when it's we're
calling it an angle because it is an
angle but at the same time stepping
aside from your party affiliation for a
second and saying I care about the
future of this country and our national
security
sort of the checks and balances and the
independence of systems like the Justice
Department and and the FBI and press
it's it's sort of a sad thing that it's
seen as picking some kind of side or
whatever that's kind of like being pro
America these are these are the main
tenets that the country is built on and
it's sad that it's becoming political
around that around those angles yeah
exactly and even staunch Trump
supporters are now turning against him
you have Ann Coulter who wrote a book
praising Trump yeah and now she's saying
where's the great negotiation where's
the bull in the china shop he wanted
that budget that the Republicans pushed
through with a joke so they're jumping
ship as well there's a lot of people
that you would not that were not never
trumpets that are also starting to
express what I will understated leak all
hesitations about some of Donald Trump's
recent behavior today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription in two I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS